Salut! Après un an et demi de vidéos, de spectacles et d'écriture de livre
J'ai décidé de faire une pause cet été!
Pour me reposer,oui,
mais aussi pour vous préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en septembre
Je vous ais demandé sur twitter si vous vouliez quelques facts rapides et divertissants en attendant
Alors pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous laisse une vidéo rapide et sans prétention
tous les jours pairs à 11h!
On se retrouve à la rentrée... et tout de suite!
Salut, alors aujourd'hui on  va parler d'une autre expression, la deuxième
de l'été. je vous avais dit qu'on en ferait 4 cet été.
Sans faire concurrence à Jonathan du Tatou évidemment.
Mais j'aimerais qu'on s’arrête quelques minutes sur l'expression "s'en battre l’œil"!
Qu'on utilise d'ailleurs un petit peu moins, hein, on s'en bat autre chose en ce moment...
Mais au départ on disait je m'en bas l’œil.
Et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand tu dis je m'en bas les nouilles.
Sauf que c'est pas exactement ce qu'on dit. On te dit "oh! tu peut être poli et utiliser la vraie expression
qui est " je m'en bas l’œil"! Alors que cette expression là est bien pire, bien plus vulgaire!
Elle date du XVIIème siècle et même Jean de La Fontaine s'en sert dans l'un de ses textes!
A cette époque, l’œil, ça veut dire un œil. Mais c'est aussi
une espèce de métaphore
d'un autre endroit du corps, c'est à dire  l'anus
Donc à cette époque l’œil ça veut dire les deux. mais dans cette expression on parle surtout d'en bas
Et les expressions de cette époque qui comportent le mot œil  veulent dire ça.
Par exemple "Se mettre le doigt dans l’œil"
Ça date de la même époque, et là tu le vois un peu différemment déjà...
Et  par extension, tous les dérivés, genre " je m'en tape le coquillard"
Beh le coquillard... tu devine bien ce que c'est...
Voila donc la prochaine fois que quelqu'un dira
"je m'en bas l’œil" ou "tu te met le doigt dans l’œil" tu lui demandera d'être un petit plus poli.
Les petites vidéos rapides de l'été
c'est une fois tous les 2 jours jusqu'au 30 août!
Si ça vous a plu vous pouvez liker et puis cliquer, non pas dans l’œil
mais ici, par là pour vous abonner.
et toujours le même planning, une vidéo tous les deux jours donc rendez-vous après demain! Tchao!
*outro*